Republican Senator Mike lead a member of
the Senate Judiciary Committee says it
would be a mistake for Democrats to
impeach President Trump he's got a new
book out it is titled our lost
declaration America's fight against
tyranny from King George to the deep
state senator Lee
good morning good to have you here good
morning good be with you want to get to
your book in just a minute but I want to
talk to you about something I think
that's extremely important you are a
former lawyer the Supreme Court has just
announced that it will take on and
decide if the Civil Rights Act of 1964
guarantees protections from work Lakes
discrimination to gay and transgender
people
this is gonna be a big deal so should it
be legal to fire someone if they are gay
or transgender the question before the
court is one of statutory construction
or rather than constitutional
interpretation there are some federal
courts of appeals that have held that
the term sex in that context includes
sexual orientation and gender identity
other courts that haven't that's why we
have a Supreme Court and this is one of
the things that routinely triggers the
Supreme Court to grant review it reviews
a very small segment of all the cases
that come before it concluded that this
one needed review because lower courts
have decided it differently got it but
the question that I asked you where it's
made its way through court should it be
legal to fire someone who is gay or
transgender I think most Americans would
have a hard time with an employer
deciding to fire someone simply on the
basis of their sexual orientation for
that reason most states nearly every
state has some type of prohibition
against that I think that Supreme Court
may actually because the Trump
administration is saying essentially yes
legally that the type that title 7 of
the Civil Rights Act it should not
include protections for gay or
transgender people right the the
argument that they're making is that the
language in title 7 of the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 doesn't extend that long now
at that for at the time they didn't have
this in mind but the fact that they
didn't have it in mind doesn't close the
question as to whether the language they
actually used is sufficiently broad to
cover this the Congress tighten that up
I suspect that Congress will be called
upon to tighten up the language it
supporting on how this
in court decides this case one can
imagine a number of different versions
of that legislation some of which could
go under support
others wouldn't there are intense
discussions right now within the
Democratic Party to impeach or not to
impeach your own record is saying no we
should not impeach because other than
the fact that you're a Republican why do
you say no to impeachment well first and
foremost the impeachment power is one
that very often instinctively feels to
the impeaching party like the impeaching
party is gaining something from it it is
gaining something at the expense of the
executive branch in some ways history
has taught us that the opposite can be
true in the absence of something that is
truly unacceptable and where you really
have to get rid of somebody and do it
quickly but when you impeach you often
end up unwittingly strengthening the
executive branch and strengthening the
executive in office at the time some of
that occurred with President Clinton
about two decades ago and I believe some
of that would be true this time around
if the Democrats made the unfortunate
choice to initiate impeachment
proceedings here do you think the mother
report will hurt the Republicans in 2020
I don't believe so a recent poll that I
became aware of yesterday I think it was
done by Rasmussen suggested that most
Americans opinion of the president of
this presidency of the Trump
administration has not changed and is
unlikely to change as a result of we
don't generally use Rasmussen in our
polling but there is actually a new poll
out from Politico actually this morning
that shows that after the Moller report
that president Trump's approval rating
is now as low as it was following the
violence in Charlottesville so it has it
is has hurt his approval ratings some of
the reports that have surrounded it i I
think might end up having a short-term
impact on how they feel about him but
they're not expected to change how they
view their big picture it didn't harm
you at all by reading the Muller report
I mean there was a key finding let's
just there were so many but let's just
take one for example that the
president's efforts to influence the
investigation were mostly unsuccessful
that that is largely because the persons
surrounding the president decided not to
carry out the orders
to orous heed his request i mean
particularly at the White House Council
John McGann sure anytime you've got a
president that president is going to be
surrounded by staff in this case he was
surrounded by some very good staff from
time to time public official president
the United States who were otherwise
will have some ideas that on further
reflection were not good ideas these
ideas were not good ideas and staff
acted appropriately here in order to
walk him off the ledge so and most we're
dealing with inchoate actions inchoate
thoughts things that never fully
culminated to doing the sorts of things
that could have been more troubling let
me ask you about your book our lost
declaration you've worked really hard to
try to keep the founders in the
conversation they are standard that they
created you know here with respect to
the Declaration the summer of 1787 when
you think about the Muller report and
the 55 men who met that summer in
Philadelphia does the behavior of the
president in the Muller report meet the
standard those men hoped for in the
presidency of the United States I'll
tell you what I think doesn't meet the
standard of what the founders had in
mind when they set up our system of
government it doesn't meet the standard
of keeping power sufficiently divided
and accountable to the people and that's
why I wrote this book I point out that
things like that Boston Tea Party
occurred as a result of a large distant
heavily bureaucratic government making
decisions for people that ended up
harming poor and middle-class people
citizens ended up taking matters into
their own hands because their government
had become oppressive so I think what
would be most stunning to the founders
is that if they looked at our system of
government today they would see this
creeping administrative state or deep
state as some have called it but that
that deep state is not accountable to
the people who woke presidents into
office I understand so that's a problem
they thought a lot about the president
that's why they made General Washington
the president of the convention Patrick
Henry didn't even go because he was so
worried about the presidency so back to
the question do you think the current
president meets the standard for the
office that they created in that summer
they created this new thing this amazing
new thing does the sitting president
meet the standard that they had hoped
for in that office I think president
Trump has done a lot of things
helped restore the kind of system of
government that was put in place by our
founding generation he has reigned in
the federal bureaucracy he's done a lot
to make the federal government more
responsive to the citizens to make it
more limited so that it doesn't have so
much discretion to do bad things that
does not mean that in every instance
he's an angel and in fact the founding
fathers understood that wouldn't be the
case that human beings are not angels
you don't someone puts him on into power
to make them a king that was the very
system we had rebelled against when we
drafted the Declaration of Independence
and so the fact that there are things in
the molar report may be unflattering at
times shouldn't surprise us you can find
unflattering things with regard to every
president in US history
the reason the declaration is so
important and the reason I've chosen to
write a book about it is to reveal that
the more things change the more they
stay the same
human nature is still such you're going
to have people who make mistakes in
office if you want to teach your son or
your daughter your grandson your
granddaughter about American history and
let them know more about America's
Founding and the principles behind the
Declaration of Independence off this
book would make a great gift for
Mother's Day Thomas Jefferson worked
very hard to get this right thank you
very much yes Senator Mike Lee